five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast you guys
already know on the Thursdays it's gonna
be me and Joseph Jitsu Japanese a collar
dude I read somewhere in the comments
they're like sometimes I just like it
when it's just you two i dude I think
that's the og cast man yeah people don't
know how many failed attempts at this
podcast I've had with some people or you
had to delete them I think I've canned
four Wow
cuz it was just me I I think what people
also don't understand sometimes is they
go oh we would like it if you would just
you know you would let them speak more I
would love it to I would [ __ ] love it
too but how we curate these
conversations is that I have to poke and
prod at the right topics and the right
questions and relate it back to me so
they feel comfortable enough to talk
about their personal experiences so I
can't just go right into an expense my
to open up yeah if you don't have a
rapport exactly so for me I I think
that's like the tricky thing about doing
podcast is to really be able to get
somebody to be comfortable enough to
tell you know strangers the details in
their lives
yeah not everyone's gonna say let's talk
about hand jobs and I do like me like
I'll go straight into it dude I don't
give a [ __ ] dude yes that's why I like I
remember when the podcast first came up
I'd address certain comments like that
you know well you talk a lot about
yourself and if they talk about their
sons later like well yeah because you
have to open up yourself in order for
someone you socially [ __ ] dumb people
don't you know that in order to to get
someone to feel comfortable you have to
give a lot of information about yourself
first to show hey check out my balls
yeah and then they'll be like well look
at my vagina you know like yeah that's
how you got to show it before they show
it but also I think that they're only
thinking from a viewers perspective
where they've heard your story or they
know about you let's know about the
guest but it's like [ __ ] that's not how
it works all the time yeah there's a
warm-up phase - it's just it's like for
example if I brought one of those
commenters on here right you think that
you just come out and just tell a really
great concise story about your personal
life and just know like divulge
everything you absolutely would not you
need to feel comfortable first and in
most cases - when you watch an interview
people are
and I'm also there promoting something
so they're coming in and they're like I
have this new book or I'm on this new
movie or on this new show and in like
when you're on the talk show or [ __ ]
anything like it's rarely with average
people they're all entertainers or
something like that so yeah those people
are [ __ ] dumb yeah it's interesting
too I just I've always had to address it
in a certain way because I don't want
them you know because I like people who
support the stuff and I understand where
you're coming from but you got to
realize just how socially awkward that
is for me to just be like so um oh yeah
so what did your dad show his dick to
you or the kid you know that would be
like between two ferns that's that's
what it is so I saw this one clip of him
talking to aquafina and he's like so
when did you become a rapist a rap a
rapper a rap are you oh wait what it
says here rap raping and he goes no
rapping yo I didn't know aquafina is
half Korean half Chinese really she's
half Korean oh that explains a lot I was
like is the Koreans back her up like
crazy yeah you know it's like I never
seen Koreans backup a Chinese person so
hard first what I looked at her face I
was like dude that's a [ __ ] John can
face if I've ever seen one so what
happened is I just try to adjust a mic
and it just popped the hell off right
now and I don't even know what the hell
to do and then a [ __ ] glass cup just
fell see this is this is my problems I
joke around with a mic too much and I'm
over here I don't know man I have to get
it like at the right place [ __ ] this
I'll do this whole thing like this yeah
so what were you talking about
oh yeah so so the ease of our
conversation right like that's what
people have to be a little bit forgiving
is David has real ass
people like real human beings that are
sometimes not entertainers or maybe
they're musicians are something that's
like they're talking isn't their craft
so they don't know how to deal with
things like this like just the other day
I was watching this pretty [ __ ] funny
interview and it was with these
Instagram models and you know the stairs
the stereotype is Instagram models have
no personality and it couldn't be
anywhere it's it's that's the truth
well like they're talking and then this
girl was like big titties booty [ __ ]
beautiful as hell and then he's like so
what brings you to California modeling
that's it and in he and he's like oh
okay
uh and then literally one like one word
it answers and a lot of people do that
with in real conversation that's what
happens is people just sit there and
they'll be like yes no oh maybe so all
right we got this dot we got this
[ __ ] mate
yeah cuz I think sometimes people think
that they're like oh I really want to
hear their personal story and I'm pretty
sure if they were not in front of a
camera on a mic they'd be able to open
up because a lot of the times when
you're put onto the spot it's like
public speaking right everybody has an
interesting story but not everybody's a
storyteller
that's the hard part that's true there's
a lot of people who have great stories
but just tell the storytelling part is
the is the really difficult part oh yeah
so I I it's I guess like maybe on my job
I'm really trying to get them to open up
without just being like what happened
here because that's where the
conversation kind of goes a little odd
for me and I think sometimes people try
to put on a show but when you get people
to cry mmm so amazing I've never been in
the room but you know I've seen yeah
when they when they cry it always throws
me off a little bit too because there's
like episodes where I start tearing up
because they throw me off I'm not trying
to make somebody cry but I just make
people angry dude I'm gonna go to
Vietnam I know man you're gonna go win
in like a couple weeks no
no not even shooting this week yeah yeah
it's crazy man ready I'm ready dude I've
been oh man I I just I feel like I need
it like I need to get out of here
I just need a reset in my life you know
traveling to me is one of the best
things I've ever decided to do in my
life yeah I think when I was so [ __ ]
broke traveling wasn't even an option
yeah it wasn't even an option I didn't
think about traveling outside of I don't
know Sacramento just to go to LA yeah
and then if somebody told me like yo do
you want to go to Australia I'm like nah
why the [ __ ] would I want to go there
like it doesn't make any small really it
would be some [ __ ] like I've always
loved to travel and always wanted to go
to travel I just didn't have the money I
think because every time I traveled I
was a missionary boring for you when you
traveled as a as a kid like for church
and stuff it wasn't boring because I had
all those great you know for fun church
activities but it was always for
religious purposes so I was I was
exploring certain parts of the country
like for example like Mexico like in
certain parts of Tijuana yeah that
wasn't very touristy I wasn't out there
you know sea diving for class no yeah I
was in a garbage heap helping out these
kids who are looking for scrap metal
parts praying with them like that's what
I was doing
hmm so it wasn't the type of travel that
most people thought I mean I got a great
like religious and spiritual experience
from it but it wasn't what normal people
think traveling is you know how they say
it's not where you're at it's who you're
with mmm I was pretty fortunate that I
had some goofball ass buddies yeah and
we could be in literal [ __ ] like
situations like that were like when you
stayed in Tijuana where there's gunshots
all night but man like the [ __ ] that
they would do and laugh at and and and
and we would kind of believe some kids
like it would just be laughs all day
long oh really
yeah there was one kid that like he had
a [ __ ] really bad right and then so the
pastor was like [ __ ] we can't stop like
we got to go pull off to the side of the
road and so this fool runs outside into
the forest to take a [ __ ] right and in
my body Eddie goes he follows of that
and we're all looking out of the bat and
the pastor was trying to tell him like
no don't [ __ ] do that we're gonna say
that way he was like come back in Eddie
and and so he doesn't know that eighties
trailing behind cuz he has to [ __ ] so
bad he's running back and apparently
Eddie waits till this dude takes off his
pants so he could [ __ ] and then he
scares him he scares him he falls and he
let him he smashes his butt on his [ __ ]
and he comes running back laughing his
[ __ ] ass off dude oh my god that's
[ __ ] disgusting oh [ __ ] it is because
he tells all of us and then of course
the pastor yells at his ass and all that
he gets in trouble and then um his name
was George but he comes out with his
hands in his pocket and he's trying to
play it off and he's walking with this
like gangster lean like a pimp and he's
walking really slow back from the forest
and everyone knows that this guy fell
and he and he [ __ ] himself this is this
is pretty horrible but like we were like
13 or 12 or something that when this
happened doesn't make it right but yeah
but things like that like we would just
[ __ ] around and um I we just have so
many great memories like that that's so
[ __ ] funny man I Church retreats are
interesting because you're in a group of
people that you don't really know until
you spend the night with them oh yeah
three or four days straight yeah there
was this dude that I know he's actually
a you tour he used to be a youtuber but
his older brother he actually became a
special ops in the Marines but he was so
[ __ ] gung-ho about the military and
about going in like he would do the you
know those pre military tests to get
into the Marines or whatever he would
practice that she was 13 make sure that
he had like 100 pull-ups and do all this
other stuff went to her a treat couldn't
[ __ ] find this fool right we didn't
know where he was this fool I [ __ ] you
not the first night slept in a tree why
because he wanted to be incognito and do
some military [ __ ] so was he did he just
come out of like a ranger school or some
[ __ ] it was like 16
watching us in a tree slept in there had
binoculars in the whole getup the hole
helped her get up he did the whole
[ __ ] military like my paint to his
face and he slit a [ __ ] tree I can't
make this [ __ ] up he's living his dream
now the next day he had I mean well he
became Special Ops which is dope so yeah
committed but I imagine how [ __ ]
weird that is just like Brett a
religious Christian retreat the [ __ ] are
you doing man cuz he doesn't get a
chance to capsule when he finally gets
it he's like here's my chance oh it's
[ __ ] crazy and uh one time so he was
actually really like tech savvy too so
whenever I had my computer problems he
would help me out in it sure you know
what this will did to me once what I
came into his house his parents weren't
there this will had all the lights off
he [ __ ] jumped me in his house took
me any hog time he was zip ties like
well back with my hands attached to my
[ __ ] ankles was he a big dude no he
wasn't he was strong and he was like
four years old in me at the time so I
was like what 1516 any hog-tie and he
was smaller than you uh close to height
but very skinny Wow and he [ __ ]
jumped me and he hugged and when he
hogtied me this full went and took a
shower and he loved you laughter you
there for like 20 minutes and did that
for me [ __ ] psychopath had [ __ ]
crazy
Korean Korean people are [ __ ] crazy
man oh yeah yeah he was really I mean he
was super nice after but yeah I think
the bullying like I cuz I went to some
Korean churches and a Korean friends and
then like it was very similar like the
bullying yeah we talked about this
before and all that so like when people
hear about the bullying like of what my
buddy Eddie did it's like they might be
like oh my god that's so [ __ ] up
especially now yeah but back then there
was a lot of love behind it I think
that's what not the bowling but then but
then you take care of each other too
like so it's a balance it's not like
hate bullying it's kind of like yeah you
do [ __ ] like that but then later it's
like you know George is hungry and then
like you know something happen or
whatever and then you're like oh yeah
like give him my food or like you'll do
things like that take care of each other
and you show love to each other and I'm
like those are the things that I kind of
probably should talk about to to balance
it out so people get a clearer picture
of
culture yeah cuz there's a lot of it's
like a frat like there's a lot of like
weird camaraderie yeah it's like hazing
yeah because you still loved dude and
then but you you bully the [ __ ] out of
them but it yeah it builds that yeah I
remember I I could too I think if I just
sat here and I talked about all the
times I saw somebody get bullied at
church I guess or hazed yeah I would be
here for hours cuz I have so many [ __ ]
stories like I remember I got purple
nurples so hard my whole chest was
bruised oh man bruised my whole [ __ ]
chest cuz he purple nurples me super
[ __ ] bad and then remember because
you know Korean people have a pond yeah
oh that's how they do it with fingers
yeah like this and they stick yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] this shit's wrong with
them dude
we call it concho and you clap your
hands like you're praying and then you
stick that in the bud to the source
Wow it's called a thumb team and they
would do [ __ ] like that they bent over
right yeah yeah there's also I remember
this dude his name is a big James
he was a [ __ ] giant big James big ol
dude I think he went to like Saint Louis
on like a football scholarship I can't
remember but it was some other of like
butt [ __ ] nowhere state then he went to
on a football scholarship he went to a
high school called Christian Brothers
and there are no Christian Brothers yeah
it was like a private school a Christian
private school and they were known for
their sports and athletics this guy big
James was so [ __ ] big he used to
scare the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me man I
his calves I remember his calves being
disgustingly huge like he could when he
would flex it was splitting the two like
two like two chicken breasts Wow and
this full we remember one time like I
think he was like trying to toughen me
up and he just kept hitting me in the
forehead with the front of his knuckle
hmm in my [ __ ] forehead and then if I
would if I would try to dodge that he
would need me in my balls oh [ __ ] and he
was so be like what was like I was a big
kid so imagine how big he was yeah
there's a [ __ ] big ass dude that
means not like that anymore but I just
remember him being [ __ ] frightening
as hell to me and those other dudes and
they was Johan Johan one time [ __ ]
pissed James off and I legit that was
the first time I think I saw a guy
realized that he just might die because
so so Johan had a
habit of being a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
married now I'm pretty sure he's a nice
dude but he was a super hyper emotional
dude I got [ __ ] stories about him for
days but Johan he so you know Korean
people pay ping ponging [ __ ] yeah
he broke one of the paddles so James is
dad at the church he was a deacon
Oh and he actually paid for all the
paddles so James got really upset
because Johan got pissed off playing
playing ping-pong he snapped one of the
paddles and there was already a habit of
people breaking the paddles and not
fessing up - who did it James break
Johan break it and then James came up to
him he goes April like my dad paced with
that stuff he goes you need to pay for
that and he goes I'm not [ __ ] paying
for that [ __ ] and he goes no you need to
pay for that my dad keeps taking money
out of his pocket to pay for these
people's he goes he's [ __ ] just
throws it right at oh oh that's
disrespectful James there was like this
metal folding chair yeah I thought James
was the Hulk James I remember James
looks at him he turns over the chair and
he kicks it as hard as he can and can
and the [ __ ] chant metal chair bent
inwards in half it collapsed in itself
oh wow like those steel [ __ ] W job
you kick it and it collapsed into us up
like a dying star yeah he kicked it like
it was a coke cat it was nothing dude
and he just turns to your heart and your
heart just goes I'm sorry that much fear
in an adult's eyes before Wow and this
is when they were grownups
this is I guess it's not an adult he was
like 18 and it was like in his he was
like but there were kids anymore like
college kids or whatever yeah they were
college and high school something like
that and that was the first time I think
I really saw somebody I actually thought
that he was gonna die to him it was
[ __ ] crazy that's crazy there's just
a lot of those like weird punking
bullying situations this podcast is
brought to you by purple have you ever
felt unsupported in your life have you
ever felt that there are just people in
your life that haven't had your back
well that's pretty normal but let me
tell you something right now you
shouldn't expect that type of treatment
from your mattress and purple my friends
will have your back and make you feel
supported I don't think people realize
how much time they spend on their back
or their side sleeping sleeping is a
huge part of your life
specifically sleeping well and the
quality of your sleep helps out with
everything life including cognitive
cognitive ability weight loss all this
stuff scientific I swear and on top of
the science part that I'm talking about
let's talk about the purple mattress
being built by rocket scientists the
technology behind it is somehow is firm
and soft at the same time it has a
material and the way that it breathes it
keeps me cool at night I sweat a lot
when I sleep I get super hot I'm always
running hot all the time and I've been
sleeping on these springy box mattress
type of mattresses and and this was
before the purple mattress so ever since
I've had that I've slept really cool my
back feels great and it's probably the
best purchase I've ever made in my life
my friends so check this out
you're going to love purple and right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text brain to eight four eight eight
eight the only way to get this repeal
out is it text brain to eight four eight
eight eight that's be are a I n two
eight four eight eight eight yeah but
that's crazy I didn't know that you
didn't really like to travel back in a
day this was something new the first
time I got a taste of like really
traveling and it's not even really
traveling was when I went to Hawaii with
us know for collaboration oh when you
met Nancy you know that that was the
first time I went to Hawaii so outside
of that you never really travel traveled
like for work or anything I went to
different states but they were all for
stand-up oh yeah so when you have that
work on your mind you can't enjoy it
because it's kind of all that pressure
the first time I ever went to Hawaii was
through collaboration and that's where I
met Nancy and Sam and stayed there and
they kind of showed me on Hawaii a
little bit and I was like yo man this
this is a place that's in the United
States but it's so different from what I
have yeah and I think that kind of
sparked my interest a lot and the first
time I did like international travel
like for fun fun was when we went to
Japan together really yeah cuz Korea
wasn't for fun those family stuff Oh
without parents that's a different
experience
exactly yeah when we went to Japan was
my first time and then I was just like
this is nice I guess like seeing how
other people live how they behave the
biggest culture shock to by the way was
kind of seeing how respectful Japanese
people were in terms of rules and laws
yeah right so if it says if there's a
sign in a subway that says you do not
chew gum you don't eat or whatever right
everybody abided by that [ __ ] and if you
did it it was like what the hell are you
doing yeah you know and I think I I
started to realize you know we always
talk about how people live differently
from us but when I see it firsthand it
actually made me change perspective oh
it blows your mind blew my [ __ ] mind
man like I was shocked
for me it was culture shock going to
Japan back in a day only because I am
Japanese but I grew up in America so my
gateway to Japan was my parents my
relatives in my church yeah other than
that like the rest of my world is
America right so when I go to Japan it's
almost like a bigger version of my
family in my church because I don't know
any other point of reference and then so
it's just weird cuz like we live very
multiculturally right and I'm like maybe
this is how white people feel like when
they live in an all-white neighborhood
and they come to LA or something and
it's like wow this is still America and
it's different
cuz um for me I'm just so used to like
being around non-japanese like you know
it might be other Asians or the Mexicans
are like I probably know more Mexican
culture than I do Japanese culture but
like being around Japanese people 24/7
was weird but calming yeah yeah it's
it's kind of it's just different cuz
you're not used to being the majority
you ever feel - there was a certain
point in my life like I don't think I
hated being Korean but it was more along
the lines of I didn't really identify
myself as a Korean until I started to
get older oh and I started realizing
there were certain attributes just I
mean number one I was born in Korea my
parents are they don't speak any English
and I think that I don't think I was
ashamed of my culture but I didn't
identify
with it very well and I and you know I
just grew up in a very diverse area so
it was and I didn't know too many Korean
people outside of my church and I wasn't
that close to a lot of the church
members except for a few people so I
don't think I kind of realized like how
important my culture was to who I am and
my upbringing and the way that I think
until I started getting older and I
started hanging around other Korean
people I'm like oh we actually have a
lot of like like-minded things and it's
because it's from a cultural aspect like
for example I thought I would never be
with a Korean girl oh and now you know
being with Muriel yeah I realized how
important it was for me to be with
somebody who understands Korean culture
oh yeah yeah that makes sense the way I
view the world how I view like like like
like familial like piety and stuff like
that how I see family friend dynamic
friend dynamic it's all very creating
etiquette yeah table conversation yeah
all that stuff yeah and in a lot of
Asians can relate to each other because
it's similar
yeah it's rooted our philosophy is
rooted in Confucianism and even though
we might grow up Christian there's still
a lot of Buddhism Confucianism and that
kind of stuff just in the subtleness of
the culture that we all kind of tie us
regardless if you're Filipino or
whatever it all that's why we have that
mutual Asian understanding with a few
like differences but majority yeah you
know we get along we get it I wonder if
sometimes I wonder too not to say that I
took the easy route in terms of a
relationship just you know dating
somebody who's Korean yeah because a lot
of the stuff was self explanatory
because she already grew up in it so I
didn't have to explain it if I just if
it was that the easier route for me than
being with somebody who was not within
my culture I don't know um because you
know like being in a serious
relationship with jazz even though we
didn't work out I feel that in some ways
that was easier even though it wasn't
the same culture you know but then again
I've never been with a Japanese girl
I've been with other Asian girls and so
that's not the same culture so it's just
it's just kind of similar because it's
Asian yeah
is weird thing like even when I when I
look at Mariel and then we have
conversations and then I'll say
something in Korean right there was
there's like a weird comfort to it I
don't know what it is but it makes you
feel a lot more connected to her I can
see that you know yeah because even with
my Japanese friends right like I have my
super American eyes like their
grandparents can't even speak Japanese
yeah and then I have my like straight
from Japan friends and even Hawk
like Hawk is British Japanese he's
floating Japanese right yeah but there
is a certain thing that tie us all even
like you know like Ryan like like he's
pretty much white oh I forget he's
Japanese yeah yeah but the but the way
he his mannerisms are the way he thinks
or handles stuff a little bit I'm like
this that's pretty Japanese yeah and
it's weird it's it's it's weird because
it's like how does that piece of you
continue on yeah I always wondered that
too yeah like um like my mom always says
to a my dad he goes you know no matter
how much you try to deny your who you
are where you came from it'll always
seep out of you
yeah it you you think you're better than
where you're from but you're not you
know like you are you are there's
something in your blood is what they say
yeah you know I I yeah for me I feel
like I'm um I'm a mix of everything but
it's I never felt ashamed or to me was
the opposite from you it was like
everyone just called me Japanese or they
called me Chinese or Asian so that's
what I thought I was you know until I
went to Japan the molder I got the more
I realized I'm an American yeah cuz I
didn't know what American was you know
when you're a kid you grow up and you
think American and you go white people
yeah that's just kind of in your head
from school and and just all this stuff
right and uh you know you are but you
what you really are is your race
yeah in America it's like you know you
know your your your a American but
you're like Asian first Yeah right
that's what you think and then when I
traveled and I'm like I look like or
they kind of look like me but this is
not my country and we do not think the
same yeah and that's when I was like oh
you know what
American is a state of mind in life and
it's a different thing from how it's
like it's it's to me it's it's more
about how you go by thinking and doing
life yeah versus like tradition or
whatever I don't know yeah I mean I
might have done a video on this back in
the day but I was talking about how
people had this weird perception of what
an American is specifically our parents
right and it's weird to us because we've
kind of evolved from whatever trials and
tribulations they went find to be an
American right Mariel tells me the story
of her mom making sure that she would
eat McDonald's so she would be more
accepted as an American right hey make
sure that you eat hamburgers make sure
that you eat french fries because if not
these American people won't accept you
and you won't be considered American
that could have been true in her parents
generation yeah and um you know there's
a lot of like for example like Japanese
people yeah who were born here a few
generations and their parents were
scared for their kids so they don't
speak Japanese I don't even try that
[ __ ] so just only know English and so
they don't know anything about Japanese
culture they can't speak the language
because it was just it was taught it
wasn't taught to them yeah for a very
specific reason and I think from those
type of experiences a lot of people now
have this weird perception of what it is
to truly be an American is it to
assimilate into this white culture or or
now for for me like definitely what
being American is is taking part of your
culture and living in this country and
kind of you know building your dream
yeah I think for me it's really about
the whole foundation and the philosophy
of this call this nation green you know
it's about the pursuit of freedom and
what freedom means to me is basically
the freedom to think the way you want to
say what you want to as long as you're
not doing anything illegal like you know
if you don't have the freedom to threat
or whatever obviously yeah you're you're
free to have opinions and you're you're
free to pretty much have a lifestyle
that you want to do and carve your own
lifestyle and do your own job your own
passion your and contribute to society
the way you want to
yeah and it's a lot of that because in
traditional culture or like specifically
Japanese culture I think that doesn't
exist yeah you know it's it's really
it's more like based off of what you
your parents want you to do or what
society is telling you to do and we have
that a little bit here but I think that
that idea of I can make it on my own I
can do what I want I can do something
different I love that I love the whole
like idea of challenging Authority if
you want to and good solid authority
should be able to take challenges and
that's what makes you stronger you know
versus traditional culture it's like
never talked about the leader never
challenged a leader state know your
place and and keep your head down and
things like that
and for me I don't like vibe with that I
think a lot of people also take for
granted how we have this this thing that
surprisingly people don't understand
that not everybody has which is choice
yeah we have a choice you you have a
choice to pursue an education or not you
have a choice to be rich you have a
choice to be poor a lot of the times
like especially like the thing about
people who still invoke like a caste
system right like they're more
classified if you have this last name
you're from this clan or whatever this
is who you are and this is where you'll
stay it wasn't long ago that Japan had
that yeah it's kind of crazy right and
yeah and in this country too what I
really do appreciate it's like I I have
we have so many options that were
burdened with options yes that's the
craziest thing to me we have so many
options of food we get fat yeah like we
have such an abundance of food to the
point where people are dying more for
being obese they are from starve I know
and it's crazy and I think some people
that are born here they don't know how
to appreciate it because once I traveled
all over and then I made friends
internationally and I heard like the
struggles that they had to go through
it's difficult to open up businesses
even in countries like Japan and
Australia who are nations that they're
not poor countries you know but they
have it way harder than we do the own it
comes to opening up businesses
with regulations and taxes and [ __ ] like
that America makes it really easy for
the common man to be somebody yeah and
that's why everyone's always coming here
you know it's like there is an American
dream but I think people that are born
here they don't see it I had a
conversation with this guy in an uber
driver while I was out in New York he I
can't remember what part of Africa he
was from but I've been gone but he was
talking about you know I just chopped it
up with him I was like oh when did you
come to the States and it was like three
years ago well as I know your [ __ ]
English is great for somebody who just
came to a country three years ago and he
goes oh oh well you know from our from
like they teach us how to speaking oh
cool
and all they still you know what they
taught you I speak English you could
tell like he learned a majority of his
English while he was here mm-hmm but I
asked him you know was like what's the
biggest reason why you came here he goes
whoa I have a cap and I know how much
I'm gonna make over there he goes I like
even if I'm here just you know a lot of
people might not look at uber driver as
a very luxurious job he goes but for me
I could make money here I could send
some back and I could they have an
apartment yeah he goes that's that's
crazy to me and so you know just that
perspective alone and that's why I also
like travelling too he gave me
perspective that's why then those
mission trips helped me out a lot yeah
say yo [ __ ] some some kids didn't really
take away what I took away from it but
it was like yo man like I got a pretty
[ __ ] good man true in and in I don't
know it all depends cuz how people
receive that information like there are
people out there that see it and then
they're just like whoa [ __ ] sucks to be
them not my not my problem right and in
like I'm just the type of person that's
like [ __ ] that could be me mm-hmm I
could be this guy I am so [ __ ] lazy I
could never live like this guy yeah cuz
I don't want to like I know a guy my
karate club I think he's from Ghana -
he's from Africa but he he's already a
doctor over there but then like they
don't have like the transferrable
licenses yeah so he has to do yes mr.
Bergin all over again from the beginning
can you imagine that like going to Metis
doing paying your dues becoming a doctor
working at a hospital
and then you come back here you got to
do it all over again and he's like ETS
was it about me yeah I was like so you
live out here with your whole family and
you know he's a student and a TA and he
does all this stuff and I'm all like
you're overqualified yes and I'm like
and okay so and he's busy dude and he
still has time to do karate and I'm all
like you are crazy exactly yeah and he's
like but I have been wanting to come to
America all my life when I have a chance
I am going to take it if I have to do
this all over again
it doesn't matter whatever I do though
yeah but that kind of stuff makes me go
man when I'm out here and I'm tripping
about YouTube's algorithms and I'm like
thinking about things that are like so
petty it just it just snaps me back into
perspective like shut up
and yeah that's what I'm saying man
sometimes yeah you know I think that's
good for us though that we we do have
this mentality of oh you know yeah it
sucks right now because of the
perspective right it's when things are
good it's okay to feel bad about it
it's just says sometimes I don't I don't
think people understand when they use
this phrase Oh like don't minimize how I
feel because you're going through things
that are worse but the flip side of that
is be mindful of what you say outside to
people because you don't know what
somebody else is going through oh yeah
that's the other side of it because I'm
getting a little tired of that phrase
just like you're minimizing how I feel
well how about I say this [ __ ] your
feelings you're feeling you I am
minimizing how you yeah because you're
not thinking about the flip side about
you complaining about luxury because
something within your luxury world fell
apart
yeah perspective why's it still sucks in
this however what you have to be mindful
of people around you you're not doing
the human part of being a human being
yeah you put that out there and you're
and then it's like complaining that you
didn't get the new iPhone and then you
need it you need it but your parents
promised you but you didn't get it it's
the same concept right and it's like
shut up shut the [ __ ] that's why I
from around the podcast I was talking
about a certain influencer who you know
she talked about like a chipped tooth
and stuff and I thought at first people
were gonna [ __ ] ream me for this [ __ ]
because you know she has a great fans
and stuff and she's a really sweet girl
too by the way
but uh no matter how much how how I how
much I like her and how much I have an
affinity towards her and how awesome of
a person she is a part of me because
number one I did grow up [ __ ] poor I
don't want to hear you complain about
the vacation trip that you took to Italy
where you chipped a tooth
you came back to America on this
whatever money that you had and then you
fixed your tooth for whatever a few
thousand dollars and got it done in a
day I don't want to hear how that's bad
luck yeah how you jumped on your fiance
or your husband's back and then chapter
two people chip their tooth every
[ __ ] day but not lose their legs yeah
what the [ __ ] and I'm not saying that
what you went through was bad but to sit
there and have a video and say oh man
I'm going through this whole life
experience and you start bawling because
you chipped your tooth it's like have
some perspective a little bit I'm not
saying what you went through wasn't bad
what I am saying is the reaction that
you got from in the pity that you're
asking for people to see of your pain is
ridiculous I mean feelings are our
feelings are always legitimate this is
what I guess feelings are always
legitimate your experience is always
legitimate but how you choose to express
that is all on you and if someone
ridicules you a you put it out there in
the world yeah because I'm not gonna be
I'm not gonna pretend like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] Starbucks order was incorrect
and they're throwing a little [ __ ]
fit like I'm not gonna pretend that that
isn't stupid I'm not gonna sit here and
go oh did you have a bad day
it's like mother [ __ ] somebody who
you didn't die yeah shut up yeah and
it's you know it's also - it's just you
know the response which is like you know
the universe is teaching me [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here
like you jumped on somebody's back and
you chipped your tooth which is a normal
progression of things that happens when
you do that on a cobblestone street or
something I almost [ __ ] all my friends
Bush cuz I have IBS what the [ __ ] did
the universe teach me something
you know like it's it's it's weird - and
you know people do a lot of this stuff
too
typically when it comes to you know
religion to bigger you know what I just
got to teaching me a lesson God ain't
teaching you [ __ ] you left you left your
car keys in your car and your car got
stolen God ain't teaching you [ __ ] yeah
you're a dumbass that's what that is you
man this is this is going into a crazy
place but it's it it's like one of the
biggest motivations why created like
Tremonti an academy yeah so like if you
guys don't know what jamali an academy
is go type it in Jamal Ian Academy comm
or just type it in Google Jamal Ian
Academy I am creating a school and it's
about lessons in life that school
doesn't really teach you and just things
that I wish I knew and I'm really sick
of the stupidity the lack of common
sense the lack of basic skills in
finance social skills relationships all
this [ __ ] and and it just blows my mind
how like we always get to this point
every time we talk about park in podcast
or JK news or whatever there's always
this point of like man people just don't
know yeah and then what I mean Society
is gonna be a certain way but what hurts
me the most is when our fan base doesn't
know and when our fan base is stuck in a
certain place because they it's almost
like I don't know if it's like impostor
syndrome or guilt but it's almost like I
keep progressing and waning in life and
I have this formula and I'm learning and
we're all getting better at life we're
killing it and they're just watching it
happen and for me
I want I want them to at least learn and
take away so when we have these like
meet and greets and we see them face to
face and and you know you always tell
the story of this kid that's all you do
funny fat fit and he became more fit
than you yeah and those are the things
that I'm looking for and I'm tired and
sick of seeing comments and and and
responses and questions and just people
lost and depressed and not doing
anything with themselves and I feel like
that is one of the biggest motivators
that has been constant as a content
creator for me and I see this in you and
I think this is what ties
of us together is there's a little bit
of Christian in us where we just have
this duty to help help give but
ultimately I'm tired of the [ __ ]
stupidity yeah
but you know like people are just
they're lost right and they don't know
how they don't know where like you said
like America has a ton of choices they
don't know where to even start like
we're burdened with too much [ __ ]
choice you don't know who's a con artist
you don't know whatever so I'm doing
this school [ __ ] all for free I'm paying
out of my [ __ ] pocket to do it yeah
and yeah it's just been a passion of
mine and it's kind of like sparking this
whole new thing for me
yeah and I think the important thing is
for people to take away is that when you
know let's say you guys do sign up for
Jill Molly and Academy it's a lot of
people are afraid to ask questions yeah
because you guys are afraid to feel
stupid and dumb and I think if anything
that I've learned and taken away from
especially you know look I'm like 31 now
is that to not ask questions it's going
to be something that's gonna hinder your
growth as a human being 100% who instead
pretend like you know something because
you're afraid of being embarrassed and
to say the phrases I don't know it's
going to be the biggest thing that's
gonna stop you from growing as a human
being number one - as an adult when you
when you [ __ ] [ __ ] that much
adults smell that [ __ ] because I've been
through that already and they they will
hate you for that [ __ ] yeah let me give
you the best example I had a business
partner who the guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] he
did not know how to say the phrase I
don't know
he knows everything huh knows everything
he was supposed to be an expertise in
everything that we knew here's the thing
about me though I'm somebody who always
asked questions and I love saying the
phrase I don't know Mom I even if I say
something if somebody goes they look it
up and go that's wrong and you know like
this I'm like okay well I get it then
you know I'm not gonna sit and argue
with you about it but we would ask him
some questions about stuff that would be
at the store or things that wouldn't
work and he would give this [ __ ]
response and very skeptical of it
because he sounds unsure and then I'm
like okay cool hold on say let me look
it up and I'm looking up I should you
not I'm looking up the stuff and I could
see him start to sweat bullets you know
and so I don't even have to look it up
at that point to know that he's wrong he
probably got his ass beat for all the
time so he's like trying to get
it's a notional answer all the time it
would be some [ __ ] like oh so why
doesn't this this the the cold brew
machine work that's like it's supposed
to lather in foam and leave like a nice
like head of foam so yeah has like this
creamy flavor to it where is it he goes
all like the there's like the specific
part that [ __ ] starts like cool well
let me look it up I'm looking it up I'm
like no it's because you don't have the
thing set right here that's like it says
right here he goes oh oh is that it okay
yeah I knew that I was like stop why are
you lying to me you know and I'm pissed
and I'm just talking [ __ ] was like why
did you just lie yeah why didn't you
just say I don't know yeah that's it all
this time
yeah you're sitting you're just [ __ ]
fumbling over your words he's because
like [ __ ] shut what the [ __ ] you wasted
my time you know like he's telling me
this explanation that clearly doesn't
sound like a make sense you just wasted
30 minutes of my time yeah you know and
it was like that type of behavior as an
adult I just don't accept anymore it's
like if you don't know something don't
be afraid to speak up and say you don't
know because if it in the long run it
still makes you look better because
you're willing to learn yeah I don't
know a lot of [ __ ] dude that's true I
think people are just scared to be a to
sound stupid and ignorant and and also
like it's embarrassing and I think
there's just a lot of shame that comes
along with it and that's why I did it
online so then like people just can
learn about basic finance credit cards
all that [ __ ] it's nice to know that
study and yeah they could but they could
see through a video yeah you know and
that that [ __ ] is and it's entertaining
because like what the [ __ ] David so on
Jamali
you know I get Craig does everything for
me yeah great you have a financial
adviser but not everyone has that yeah
yeah they don't have any they don't have
that luxury you know like it's important
to know these like basic things good I
think that's how the reason why
knowledge is also very important in
terms of stuff that's stuff that I in my
personal opinion you should know is
because there's a lot of people that can
[ __ ] you over if you don't have this
knowledge yeah you gotta at least know
it so then when you hire the person you
know what the [ __ ] you're hiring them
for you know like a counter or whatever
and it um you know I for me money has
never been an emotional or touchy
subject but I'm starting to realize how
emotional people are and secretive they
are about money yeah because I went down
this rabbit hole of thinking about why
is it that they say like over 50% of
Americans are like a paycheck to
paycheck away to bankruptcy or just like
not being able to [ __ ] live and you
have all these 50 something year olds
like a [ __ ] ton of these guys don't have
more than two thousand dollars in their
bank account yeah by the time you're 50
something you should have two thousand
dollars in your bank account for sure or
else what the [ __ ] did you have you been
doing with your life you know and so
it's I don't think it's the problem with
the economy because we live in the
richest [ __ ] country in the world I
think it's about budgeting and how
people are managing their money and
spending and all this [ __ ] but no one
wants to talk about that budgeting is
something that's very hard for people
even for me to I think I live a little
beyond my means but you know I'm I'm
always in the positive I'm always you
know I'm always saving I could save a
lot more you know I know you I know your
situation and you're just you're just
being [ __ ] a cheap-ass Asian because
you Minh you cover enough yeah there's
people out there that should not be
buying another car yeah because they're
gonna yeah they can't even afford it
they can't even afford the gas in that
car you know it's it's really shocking
how but here's your something very very
small and that I think a lot of people
say that I don't know it doesn't bother
me so much but it helps me to realize
how the concept of saving is it's
something that's really elusive to a lot
of people for example I always hear this
phrase and this is from people that I
that I see I could look in your in your
photo alone I already know that you can
afford this just on the clothing that
you have on your body I can't I don't
have enough money to travel lies if you
have if I look at your pro Instagram
profile right I see you with Air Max
Mendez and I see you with a bait hoodie
those two things alone
you could have traveled with yeah but
you chose
and $600 on air max Mendez you chose to
spend 300 bucks on that Bay puddi so
that alone you're already close to about
a grand mm-hmm
you spend a thousand dollars on the
clothes to make yourself look good then
instead of taking that money and
enriching your life to travel which I'm
not saying that it's for everybody but
you verbally have said you want to
travel if you want something that's
financially there's ways to do it
if you saved 20 bucks a month you could
literally go around and beg for $20 a
month and if you're that way around you
figure that out for yourself right yeah
if people think - Bigelow well you have
a lot of money so that's why you could
travel whenever that's not true I save
up to travel yeah even Muriel knows I
have this little jar outside yeah but I
don't technically need to have a jar to
put money in but I do that as I like the
visual of it so it's like cool when I
travel if I want to spend like 600 bucks
on food alone when I travel for two
weeks I'm going to take all the change
that I have throughout the year and put
it in there yeah right now it's almost
been a whole year I I used it once
already when we went to Hawaii and I
still have 200 something bucks in it
just from money that I've put in here
and there that I would have spent either
to going out to eat yeah and would have
spent on a coffee I decided to put it in
the travel jar instead so even if you
guys think that financially I'm more
stable than you even when it comes to
travel I still save a little bit here
and there for it I mean the reason why
we become rich is because we we learn
how to do things like that yeah and we
haven't always been rich you know we
weren't born that way and if you could
save money to buy those shoes yeah you
could have done the same the other way
around when I when I first started doing
music this guitar that you see right
here this guitar is it's by a company
called seagull I [ __ ] love that I
wanted this guitar I was making 200
bucks a week at the Men's Wearhouse at
most about 150 to 200 dollars a week it
took me damn your [ __ ] year to say
but to buy this guitar but you did it
but I [ __ ] did Yeah right
I saved up I scrounged and by the way -
I was living with my cousin paying him
rent yeah and I had to work about I also
I worked at the church I worked a little
bit for my parents and then I worked
also a part-time job so I had to save up
a little bit from one of those jobs
up a little bit just to pay off to get
that guitar because I wanted to have it
and I think if you took that same a same
type of intensity that you do for
material objects yeah you do the same
paper travel and I mean I haven't even
paid for travel in the last two years so
there's there's travel hacking yeah
that's completely legal and things like
that I'm gonna be putting on the page
too but because people don't understand
credit cards and I just released basic
understanding of credit cards there's a
whole thing called points that people
see the rewards and all that but if you
understand how to use it right think
things like you're gonna buy anyway like
you're gonna buy groceries you're gonna
buy your clothes you're gonna buy all
these things right over the years you
rack up these things called points and
as long as you can budget and find pay
off your bill every month you get free
money basically points to me is free
money because it racks up and you can
use that for airplane tickets you could
use it for hotel all that stuff and it's
like why would why would they do that
why would they give you free [ __ ] why
would credit car companies give you all
this free money well that's how they
bring people in right like they make it
into a game and then people spend more
because they go oh well I'm getting
points anyway the key is to spend on
things that you were already gonna spend
on anyway so if you were gonna save up
and buy this guitar or whatever you use
the you know you save up and you get the
money first and then you spend it but
you use your credit card and then you
pay it off immediately but you get the
points for it
mm-hmm and then so so the credit card
company they give you these points
because they want you to sign up because
they know most people will [ __ ] up yeah
most people overspend most people will
go crazy and then they won't they'll go
oh well maybe I'll split this and start
paying it off little by little that's
when you get charged interest and that's
when they start making more money on you
but the key of the game is if you keep
paying everything off you just rack up
the points and then you get rewarded for
that and so but if you don't understand
any of this stuff and this is basic -
this is not even hacking like this is
just normal [ __ ] if you understand it
you're gonna benefit really well and
I've racked up so much points over the
years like I'm literally all the
traveling that I've been doing for the
past two years hotel room all that it's
all been points yeah all of it yeah so
so if like your Instagram you know kid
and for example like if they're gonna
buy a thousand dollars worth of clothes
put it on the card get those points you
know yeah and that's only a fraction of
what I do like I open up a ton of cards
and I kind of hack the system a little
bit and I get a ton of good free points
so yeah and there's just you know it
also goes to show you know you really
have to figure out what you put value
into ya know like I think the kid with
the whole paper and stuff like that it's
just also - if you find value in
material things and that's your [ __ ]
that makes you happy then that's
probably the life that you want to live
I don't know if traveling it's gonna
really enrich your life and yeah that
you know they don't get their babe
sweater dirty and that'll make them sad
yes maybe traveling is not for you maybe
you just want to just you know floss and
stay good yeah the for the whole thing
about Jamal Ian Academy though it's it's
really about working on yourself and
making this all into a game like your
life is like a Sims you know and
whatever you got you there's a system
and there's a there's a way to get
better at everything so don't let don't
don't be like a victim to life you know
like control it like you know you can
win it so regardless if it's your
friendships your social life you know
your money your career all these things
we weren't taught these things right we
had to figure it out ourselves but so
many people are just completely lost
like they like a lot of people like they
don't even know how to get a promotion
and how to negotiate for higher higher
salaries they don't know any of that
stuff yeah they just think if I work
hard and I stay here and then like in
two years I'm gonna go in there I'm
gonna march into the office and say I
demand a raise and I'm like bro that's
not how it works
yeah but no everyone doesn't know that
do they just think a man like I've been
spending a lot of time here like I think
I deserve more money yeah and it's like
dude
if I can show you guys how to make an
extra thousand bucks a month or two
thousand bucks a month its it's easy if
you think about it right like at this
point if I told you hey David can you
make another thousand bucks a month
you'll be like yeah it's [ __ ] easy
yeah without using your influencer
skills yeah because your mind is just
like by running businesses by knowing
how like I'll figure it out you'll
figure it out without using any [ __ ]
technology like this I'd figure it out
dude yeah because I've understand you
become a boss when you run companies
when you know how things work you know
how to tie everything together
and then there's like a show right now I
think there's like a billionaire or a
millionaire or whatever he does these
challenges were like for like a month or
whatever he he has no money or just a
hundred bucks and he has to become rich
again or whatever I think he's gonna be
able to do it that's pretty awesome
yeah there's ways man and I always tell
like I don't always tell this but you
know I know I know people who have asked
advice about like money stuff and I what
I'm seeing as a cyclical issue is that a
lot of the times too people want to make
money only the way that they want to and
they don't want to do the grunt work so
for all people say like oh I you know
I'm just like short on cash I don't I
can't make money right yeah and what I'm
finding out too it's it's not that you
can't make money you only want to make
money the way you want to make you proud
- proud yeah right for example like I've
had people come up to me and ask me like
yo like I need to borrow like I don't
know like let's say even something as
small as like a hundred some bucks right
and my mind I'm like you need to borrow
a hundred or something bucks as an adult
um there are ways to make that money
yeah you number one that's poor prep on
your part that means that you weren't
financially smart with your [ __ ] and
you're just living paycheck to paycheck
and when you when there are options for
you not to do it if you can stay afloat
that means that means your basic
necessities are covered and at that
point everything else is gravy right
like here's something small like just
this is just me off the top of my
[ __ ] head right let's say I don't
know something happened and I lost all
my money I had to lose
apartment or everything else like I
don't know why I think about the [ __ ]
but I actually do think about the stuff
a lot I do too
yeah I think that's what keeps us
hustling yeah I think about this I go
okay I probably set up my car live out
of my car for a little bit and if I
don't have since I don't right now I
don't really own a card that's uber
worthy yeah I would go I since I have
good credit I would go and I would rent
a car right use that rent car money and
I would drive enough where I pay that
pay that minimum off and then I would go
ahead and do overrides pay that off work
[ __ ] nights and hours and days and I
try to go work a part-time job on my off
hours and then on my off I would do over
and then other than that I would think I
think about like some [ __ ] of going to
like doing garage sales selling
liquidating all my [ __ ] out using that
cash to start up and maybe do another
business like there's like somebody
that's dough yes I'm always thinking
like what would happen tomorrow right
and it sounds easier said than done and
think for most people like oh I would
love to see you do that but trust me
I've been away were situations in that
I've been in way more situations if I
went bankrupt and then it has to be
legal that's the that's the game right
yeah on this way and if do I have
anything like my car anything you still
have all your assets mm-hmm you do have
your car do I have somewhere to shower
and all that you have to figure that out
okay so so I have like my car I don't
have a house I
what about like do I have my things like
my guns and my watches and yeah so I
could sell all that oh okay but maybe
okay maybe I'll make it harder on myself
what if I have nothing the banks came in
and took everything right and I have you
guys right so first thing I'll do is
I'll be like hey David can I crash on
your couch and you'll be like [ __ ] no
[ __ ] you try to make it really hard for
yourself dude I'd have to literally
sleep somewhere like I'd have to be a
homeless man and sleep somewhere yeah
and you know what it would it be really
hard is if I don't know anybody in the
city like if I'm just in Chicago or
somewhere you know and no one knows who
I am and it's just me oh [ __ ] that
kind of rough that would be hard I think
the first thing I definitely would do
just so I have a place to shower is I
would get a 24 hour gym membership but
how about if you don't have any money
how do you get membership I have to pay
for money then oh let me just pay for
money I'm not I'm not above begging for
money if I have okay so if I have a ID
and I can walk into a bank and open up a
bank account right I can also open up a
credit card because you know I'll have
like maybe my credits not [ __ ] up
maybe it's just average or whatever so I
open up like a like a two hundred dollar
credit card right take that walk to the
gym what you know that they have to like
those super deals looks like 10 bucks
then you can get that for 10 bucks right
and then shower all that stuff try to
get a job at the gym well I'm there if I
can't get a job there then I'm gonna
walk out and I'm gonna walk into every
single store in that Plaza to try to get
the the goal is to get a job immediately
yeah and obviously if you can't then you
got to go find a place to sleep
shelters or you just got a squat you
just got to find a place where you can
sleep like a homeless man yeah yeah and
every day I would just do the same thing
until I get a job yeah and then when I
get a job I'll probably you know like
you know you could get motels like and
you could or you could be like I want a
whole week there or whatever but if I
have my phone I'll probably like do
Airbnb or whatever for and then I would
stay at the Airbnb and then I'll tell
the owner my situation and then I'll
negotiate a lower fee but I'll stay
there for a month yeah and then I'll
slowly start building but then I would
immediately start looking for businesses
that are being sold so like I'll look
for a business where someone doesn't
want to deal with it anymore and then I
would look for a bank that could fund me
and then I would buy that business with
the bank's money
so I would skyrocket like a [ __ ]
and then boom I'm back in business
yeah this is so funny like it I know
that for a lot of people they go yeah
right
you know easier said I mean these are
all sinners that were just playing in
our head yeah you know and by the weight
like this blanket statement that I'm
saying - I'm not considering in the fact
that let's say it's like somebody with
like a wife and a wife and like four
kids well that's not hard if I'm talking
about the the kid who is like relatively
has a roof over his head it's just him
that he has to worry about or she heard
that she has to worry about this is this
these are the type of people that are
approaching me this is not the the the
person will who's like $10,000 in debt
a family of four where the reset and
start from scratch
and you have nothing yeah but the
clothes on your back that's but you have
a ID yeah I think I think that's cool
like as long as you don't have like [ __ ]
credit and [ __ ] like and if you have a
criminal history like if you don't have
that then I think you know I think
recess but said the best man he goes he
says I work every day as if I don't have
a penny in my bank account I wish I
could do that yeah I don't work like
that but Will Smith says the best though
what the hell
but Will Smith does it really well and I
don't think that i think that that's a
it's an extreme but it's a good
mentality to have in terms of staying
motivated - yeah can you - work because
it's true you don't know when
something's gonna happen to take it all
away you don't I really don't so and we
have very limited time and I just want
everyone to do good because I think at
the end of the day like what I'm feeling
is that now we're learning we're growing
and I just want to play that forward and
I want people that enjoy our
entertainment to also be able to enrich
their lives you know yeah 100% yep yeah
guys well that wraps up this podcast and
yeah man hope you guys enjoyed that
podcast check out the Joe Malin Academy
and yet you could catch us on Spotify
iTunes any type of audio platform give
us that five star and share this podcast
with your friends because you guys
already know we're here to be with you
on your everyday life your commute
whatever y'all need we're your friends
man
Oh G cast today thank you very much bye